So the MCS tree barrier is, it's also a
tree barrier. It's a modified tree barrier, and what
you'll notice, and once again, to make life simple,
I'm showing you an arrangement of the MCS tree
barrier with with 8 nodes. And it's a 4
ary arrival tree. So the arrival tree and the
wake-up tree are different in the MCS algorithm. The
arrival tree is a 4 ary tree, and I'm showing
the arrangement for N equal to 8. There are
2 data structures that are associated with every parent, and
and this one data structure is what is called
have children, and the other data structure is what is
called child not ready. And I'll describe to you
what each one of these things is. Have children is
a data structure that is associated with every node.
And this data structure is going to have meaning only
when a node is also a parent. So for example, if you look at this arrangement,
node P0 has 4 children, P1, P2, P3 and P4. And if you look at node P1,
it has 3 children. And so, P5, P6 and P7, has 3 children. And so we have a total
of 8 processes, so we've got all 8 processes accounted for here. And therefore,
these guys, P2, P3, P4, all the way up to P7, they're not as lucky as P0 and P1.
They don't have children. So P2 through P7, they do not have children.
And therefore, their HaveChild vector is, is, is
false. So what you see here is a
HaveChild vector and the HaveChild vector is, is
true for P0 in all the big positions.
And indicating that it has because it's a 4
ary tree, it can potentially have up to four children.
And yes, P0 has 4 children. And the have child
vector is true all the way, whereas, for P1, the
have child vector is true for the first 3 children
and false for the fourth because it has only 3
children. And these guys don't have any children. And similarly,
these guys don't have any children. So, the HaveChild vector
is completely false for P2 through P7. Now what
about this Child Not Ready data structure? The Child
Not Ready data structure is a way by which
each of these processes has a unique spot in
the parent to signal when they are arriving at
a barrier. So what I'm showing you here, the
arrows here are showing you the specific spot in
this data structure, the child not ready data structure
associated with his parent, for each of the child,
there is a unique spot for this guy to
indicate that they've arrived at the barrier. And similarly,
for this set of children, the parent is P0 and
each child has a unique spot in the parent's
child not ready vector to indicate that they've arrived
at the barrier. So the black arrows in this
structure that I'm showing you is just showing the arrangement
of the tree. And in terms of the,
the parent child relationship for the 4-ary arrival
tree. And the red arrows are the ones
that are showing you the specific spot where
a particular child is going to indicate to the
parent that they have arrived at the barrier.
And as you can see that since P1
has 3children, the fourth spot is empty indicating it
has to wait only on 3 children to know
that the value is completed on the tree and so
it can move up. So, the algorithm for barrier arrival
is going to work like this. When each of these processors
arrive at a barrier, what they going to do is
they going to reach into the parent data structure, very specific
spots, statically determined. That's important,
right? So it's statically determined
that this is a spot that P5 is going to indicate
to the parent that it has arrived. This
is the spot that P6 is going to indicate that
it has arrived. P7, and similarly, once all these
guys have arrived at the barrier, P1 can check,
and the way P1 checks is, just sees whether
this CN vector has ones in all these pods.
If there is ones in all these pods, it
can spin on this, and therefore, it knows that
its children have arrived at the barrier. Once
its children have arrived at the barrier, then it
can move up the tree similar to what we
saw in the vanilla tree barrier before. P1 is
going to move up, and it's going to inform its parent.
And the way it does is by going to
a specific spot in the parent's child not ready
vector. And there is specific spot assigned for P1.
It's going to set this to indicate that it has arrived
at the barrier. So what P0 is doing is waiting on
everybody arrive. If P0 is the first let's say to arrive
at the barrier. It's basically waiting on everybody else to arrive
at the barrier. Could be P0 is the first one or
the last one, it doesn't really matter. When P0 arrives at
the barrier, it is going to wait on this child not
ready all the bits being set by the children. And so,
when each of these nodes arrive at a barrier, they
know because of the arrangement of this data structure, they know
their position in the data structure relative to other processes arriving
at the barrier. And therefore P2, when it arrives at a
barrier, It knows that all it has to do, given
the structure, it has to go to this part on the
parent vector and set it to 1. P3 has to go
to this part set it to 1 and so on, okay?
And so once it is done, P0 will know
that everybody has arrived at the barrier. So, that's the
arrival at the barrier. So once again, the recap. The
arrival tree is a 4-ary tree. And the reason why
they chose to use a 4 ary tree is because
there is a periodic result backing the use of 4
ary tree leading to the best performance, and that's the
reason that they, they chose this particular arrangement. And the
second thing that I want you to notice is that
each processor is assigned to a unique spot by construction,
a unique spot in this 4 ary tree. And because
of its unique spot, a particular process on may have children,
or may not have children and in this case, I
showed you that P0 and P1 are have children, and
the rest are not as lucky, because N is equal
to 8. The other nice thing about this particular arrangement is
that in a cash coherent multiprocessor, it
is possible to arrange so that all the
specific spots that children have to signal the
parent can be packed into one word of
a processor and therefore, a parent has to
simply spend on one memory location in order
to know the arrival of everybody, so it
doesn't have to individually spend on memory locations
for different processes, they can all be packed
into one word, and the cash coherence mechanism
will ensure that P0 is alerted every time
any of these guys modify this shared memory location.